so let's talk about coffee substitutes
you know some people don't want to
consume all this caffeine because it
triggers the adrenal and it definitely
can affect your sleep and your weight
loss and a lot of other things so when
you consume decaf you have to realize
that 97% of it's decaffeinated there's
that 3% cap being so it's not 100% and
it does go stale twice as fast as
regular coffee so when you buy it off
the shelf make sure you read the label
to make sure it's not too old and the
last thing is you want to consume water
processed or Swiss water process you do
not want to consume the regular method
because there are certain chemicals in
there and it's just not not good I would
also get an organic decaf versus just a
commercial decaf so then let's talk
about de Chino - Chino is amazing
because there's no caffeine it tastes
very similar to coffee
it's made from chicory root carob barley
nuts in cocoa so it only has 4 grams of
carbohydrate per serving and only one
gram of sugar so it's totally fine and
you'd be surprised how close it is to
coffee then we have Roma which is a
roasted barley and chicory and has rye
in there very similar to Ticino slightly
different no caffeine two brands of
carbohydrate one gram of sugar so that's
another great substitute so either one
of these three are totally fine if you
wanted to avoid caffeine thanks for
watching hey you probably already
subscribed but if you haven't press this
little button down below and I will keep
you updated